welcome back in the last video I was
confusing you with compound interest and
now I will continue to do so but the
general notion is you know I threw out
this hundred percent interest rate and
and that was if you just you know we
just say you pay me a hundred percent of
what you borrow after a year and then we
talked about what what happens if
instead you know you want half the rate
for six months but then I will compound
that interest over the next six months
so then we said what happens if it's for
every month or every day and this was
the case for every day and if I charged
you 2.7 percent every day but I compound
it for 365 days it becomes I'm just
using Excel here let me clear all of
this it becomes 1.0 to seven to the
365th power go i I'm using my Excel
incorrectly oh that's not right let's
see plus 1.0 to seven to the 365th Oh -
seven to the 365th power now I'm making
a mistake here let me make sure I got
this 1.0 to seven right so if I take
100% and I divide it by 365 so 100% is
same thing as 1/3 sixty-five that is oh
it's point oh oh sorry so I'm not I'm
not going to charge a two percent a day
yeah that seems high I'm going to charge
you one point that is zero zero two
seven four I'm charging you 0.2% right
this would be this is a little kind of
one percentage place so this is 0.2% so
I'm charging you Oh point two seven four
percent percent per day I don't know I
put brackets around that so if I were to
compound that over 365 days you've taken
to the 365th power and what does that
get me so let's see if I do plus one
point zero two seven four
to the 365th power I get two point seven
one four eight it equals two point
that's how much you're going to owe me
if you just keep the money you keep kind
of reborrowing it every day you'll owe
me two point seven four eight dollars
after the end of one year now let's say
that's not enough for you because this
interest rate is so high you want the
option to pay it up by the hour you want
this thing to compound every hour of the
day so let's see let's first of all
figure out how many hours there are in a
year so let's see this in a year there's
365 days times 24 hours per day
so there's 8760 hours in a year and then
if we want to divide 100% which is just
1 divided by whoops plus 1 divided by
that number I could charge you point o 1
what is that number
yeah it's point o 1 1 4 so hourly
compounding hourly compounding I should
have been doing this in green is its
money but let's see hourly compounding I
will charge you 100 percent divided by
the number of hours in a year which
equals 0.01 one 4% per hour so over a
year I would take it to this power right
so let's say after one hour you'll owe
me one point oh one sorry it's oh one
percent so it's oh oh oh one 1/4 that's
how much you're going to owe me after
one hour so very you know one dollar
plus a very small fraction of a cent but
then after another hour you're going to
owe that times that again you're going
to because that's this will be the new
principal after an hour so then you're
going to
oh that same fraction times it again
alright after and then after three hours
you'll multiply it again
so after the total number of hours in
the year which is 1.000 one one four
hours and there's 8760 hours in a year
let's see let's see what you'll owe me
so if I do plus one point zero one one
four to the 8760 a--the power two point
seven one four four three so now you at
the end of the year after compounding
roughly 8700 hours you'll owe me two
dollars 71 cents and then and then some
fractions of a penny and I know you
thought that these videos were about E
and and you're just learning about how
to how to take advantage of someone in
need but there should be something
interesting here that maybe you've
observed that the you know when we
started compounding at first the you
owed me two dollars just when I did you
know just one period which is the whole
year then it got to what was it to 25
and then it got kept it kept getting
higher as we compounded shorter and
shorter periods but it seems to be
approaching some number it seems to be
approaching right when I compounded
every day you at the end of the year you
owed me $2 71 and some change and then
if I compounded every hour which is 24
times as many compounds you still owe me
a very similar number so it seems like
it's gravitating towards this this
mystical number here and that mystical
number is e so let's let's kind of
formalize what what I've been meandering
around for for a video and a half now
and I'll switch colors so in general the
amount of money you owed me at the end
of the year was the amount you borrowed
the amount you borrowed let me do it in
blue let's call that the principle and
that's not bright enough the principal
times 1 plus and what was the interest
rate
it was 100% 100% divided by the number
of times you wanted to compound in the
year we'll call that n right and we
raise that to the N power so in the case
of when there is only one compounding
period where you just borrowed it for
the year and we the principle in our
example was 1 right so this is just 1
times the principal is just what you
borrowed 1 plus 100% is the same thing
as 1 right or 1.000 and when there was
one compounding period we just did that
and sorry we just did that and you owed
me two dollars at the end of the year
and this is exactly what I've done in
the last video in the 1/2 I'm just
formalizing it with a couple of
variables when we compounded it every
month it turned into this the principal
Bardot's 1 times 1 plus 100% over 12 to
the 12th power which equaled let's see I
erase the numbers so I will redo it so
it's 1 plus 1/12 let me let me put that
equals equals 1 plus I'm using Excel for
those of you who have never seen it
before 12 to the 12 power and that equal
to point 6 1 3 2 point 6 1 3 and when I
compounded every day I got the principal
you barred was that times 1 plus 1 over
365 to the 365th power and that equal to
2 point 7 1 and then sometimes something
so as you see it as I make n larger and
larger in this original equation I
approach this magical number I approach
this magical number 2 point 7 1
something something something and that
magical number is e and it amazes me
that this this and it never repeats it's
one of these transcendental numbers like
pi and later on in future videos we'll
see that it shows up in all over the
place it shows up in random
combinatorics it shows up in
and complex analysis and as we see here
and maybe most importantly it shows up
in compound interest so in general what
we could say is the limit and the limit
is just what happens you know as you
approach something the limit as n
approaches infinity and in our example
that's as we compound over smaller and
smaller periods of time of 1 plus 1 over
N to the nth power is equal to this
magical number and I'll do it in a in a
bold color is well that's not that bold
but I'll highlight it with another bold
color is e and that is equal to 2.71 I
forget all the digits keeps going on and
you could and it's really fun to
experiment put in a crazy huge put put
in like a million there and if you put
it there you have to put a million there
too and you'll see that the larger not
larger numbers you get you just get
closer and closer and closer to this
number in a fun project would see how
many digits of e how many digits of e
you can get but the fact that as you as
you compound something over smaller and
smaller periods it converges to this
number to me is pretty interesting so
with that out of the way in the next
video I'll show you how to figure and so
in the limit as n approaches infinity
what are you doing you're actually
compounding continuously you're
compounding every zillions of a second
and you can the fact that you can
actually calculate an interest rate at
at compounding every zillions of a
second to me is a fairly amazing result
but anyway I'll see in the next video
cuz everyone out of time